my character name is rise o and riser is
a great assessing the movie they were
forgiving who you are is producing and
James MagTek directing him stunt him
from the 300 and matrix they're the best
I had a make my body fit like Bruce Lee
I trained for eight months
five days a week eight hours a day even
though everybody took care of me but I
still got hurt you really love chocolate
but when I was doing stunts I never eat
chocolate just I am only chicken breast
and vegetables you know no sugar no soul
nor any sauce yeah it is hard did you
say that it is real no makeup there's no
wire in no camera tricks we had a
classic filming so just you know there
is just safety wire
I learned a lot of you know much Laurent
Tai Chi kickboxing weave sword and
double soy Chan got Chinese my favorite
things so powerful so fast
I worked hard that's it no chocolate no
hamburger
no french fries you know the most
hardest part is when I finished the
Ninja Assassin
I said normal work out normal vegetables
normal training
I hate training I hate a pax you know
mostly is good